Ok, ok, ok.
*Squeezie qui dessine une moustache,..*
*Puis deux dents en moins x)..*
*Et qui gribouille sur le "Cyprien" se trouvant dans "#CyprienFirst" puis note son pseudo en haut, ce qui donne..
#SqueezieFirst ~*
Hop là, ça c'est fait, on peut commencer la vidéo maintenant
Attendez, apparemment les youtubeurs se font démonétiser des tas de vidéos
Et apparemment, les youtubeurs font aussi ce métier uniquement pour l'argent
Est-ce que ça voudrait dire qu'en assemblant ces deux informations, on obtiendrait…
Des youtubeurs au Pôle Emploi ?
OOOOOHHH !
Les amis aujourd'hui on va parler des changements qui y'a eu sur YouTube ces derniers temps
Y'a pas mal de choses à dire.
J'vais aborder ça en trois grands arcs
Comme un animé japonais stylé
Sauf qu'ici il n'est ni question d'animé,
Ni question d'un truc stylé.
La dernière fois que j'avais fait ce genre de vidéo c'était y'a un bon moment déjà
Où j'avais parlé de la mode de dire aux gens à tout prix d'aimer la vidéo
AIMEZ LA VIDEO
MAINTENANT AVANT LA SUITE
C'était y'a déjà un moment maintenant ça s'est complètement calmé
Tout simplement parce que ça ne sert à rien
Les gens ont compris que ça ne référençait pas mieux les vidéos !
On va donc commencer par parler de l'algorithme
Le fantasme de tous les créateurs
Celui dont on veut percer les secrets
Celui qui peut rendre quelqu'un riche et connu
Ou alors pauvre et dans l'indifférence totale
j'ai pas mille trucs à dire dessus parce que Youtube ne donne toujours aucune info
Pour la simple et bonne raison que sinon les gens réussiraient à le comprendre
Et à faire ce qu'il faut pour que leur vidéo soit mise en avant
Même si elle ne le mérite pas du tout...
Mais de ce que j'ai remarqué, je trouve que ça va vraiment mieux.
En tout cas l'onglet des tendances est vraiment bien géré par rapport à avant je trouve.
Et je dis ça alors que moi je me retrouve mille fois moins en tendances que par exemple il y a un an.
Mais c'est mérité dans le sens où actuellement l'algorithme se base sur combien de vues fait ta vidéo
en moyenne dans les 24 premières heures, ou dans les 12 premières heures, ou dans les 6 premières heures
Et ce qui est bien avec ça c'est que ça laisse la place à des nouvelles  personnes, c'est pas toujours les mêmes qui sont en tendances
Et on découvre maintenant, je trouve beaucoup plus qu'avant des nouveaux créateurs
Pas forcément, mais en tout cas des créateurs dont on avait pas forcement entendu parlé
Et c'est hyper bien pour eux! C'est eux qui ont besoin de cette visibilité
C'est eux qui ont besoin de ce coup de pouce
Et c'est un système qui est génial !
Voilà je voulais vous en parler parce que
On a très souvent chié sur l'onglet des tendances, sur comment ça marchait, etc
Parce que les youtubers dont moi, on a de l'égo
Quand on est pas mis en avant par
OH LE GRAND MAÎTRE YOUTUBE
On le vit mal !
On se sent rejeté !
JE MÉRITE MA PLACE EN TENDANCE, QUI ETES VOUS YOUTUBE POUR EN DÉCIDER A MA PLACE !
La ferme !
C'est vraiment ça le raisonnement, c'est fou !
Eh bah aujourd'hui, j'ai l'impression que ça fonctionne comme je viens de vous le dire, alors
Attention, c'est ce que je pense, Youtube n'a rien communiqué là-dessus
Mais je vois de plus en plus de vidéos, qui avant n'étaient jamais en tendances, et qui pourtant sont très cool
Il y a par exemple, il y a pas longtemps la copine de DEO TOONS, qui a lancé sa chaîne Youtube
Et DEO TOONS en a parlé dans une de ses vidéos
Du coup, la première vidéo de sa copine a fait beaucoup beaucoup de vues pour une nouvelle chaîne Youtube
Et hop, elle a tapé le top 1 tendances
Et c'est mérité, c’est très bien !
Voilà, c'est mon avis sur ça
En tout cas, je suis très content de ça, c'est trop cool, ça permet aux jeunes créateurs d'être vraiment mis en avant
Et de gagner beaucoup en visibilité
C'est qu'en ont besoin, je le rappelle, donc c'est magnifique
Voilà
La deuxième chose
La raison pour laquelle les youtubers ne font plus leurs courses
aux Galeries Lafayette
Maintenant ils font leurs courses à Leader Price
N'est-ce pas écœurant ?
Ne méritent-ils pas mieux ces GRANDS YOUTUBERS
ces DIEUX ?
LA DEMONETISATION !
AH AH AH AH
*s'étrangle*
Alors Universal Music, vous connaissez très bien
Le plus gros label du monde, je pense, ou l'un des plus grand en tout cas
démonétise des tas et des tas et des tas de vidéos
Je crois que Terracid a la médaille d'or de la démonétisation, vraiment il s'est fait niqué
Un nombre collossal de vidéos,vous savez tous comment sa marche,voilà
on utilise un extrait peu un porte sa durée,d'une musique qui est soumis à des droits d'auteurs
donc qui est généralement publié par Universal
et distribué par universal
du coup quand le robot Youtube détecte que tu a utilisé cette musique là
il te dit Holala tu n'a pas le droit,je te démonétise
ou alors quand le robot détecte pas le truc,c'est directement quelqu'un de chez universal qui tombe sur ta vidéo
et qui revendique la démonétisation
j'ai moi même eu des tas et des tas et de tas de vidéo démonétisée
Baa toute façon plus t'a de vidéos mises en ligne depuis toute ses années
plus t'a de chance d'avoir eu des démonatisations
Parce qu'à l'époque, on s'en battait les couilles d'utiliser des musiques soumises à des droits d'auteurs
Alors qu'on savait très bien qu'on avait pas le droit !!
Et c'est ça qui est hypocrite,je trouve, de la part des youtubers
Youtube ou nos Network ne nous ont jamais dit
"Allez-y utiliser ses  musiques qui sont soumises à des droits d'auteurs.Y'a pas de soucis.Il ne vous arrivera jamais rien "
Pas du tout!
On savait tous très bien que c'était interdit
Mais on savait aussi qu'ils ne pouvaient pas controler toute les vidéos de tout le monde
Et que le robot des fois quand tu mettais la musique un peu plus aïgue  ou un peu en accélérée il passait à côté
Mais c'est parce que le robot de Youtube passe à côté que t'a le droit pour autant
Et donc là,on c'est pris un retour de flammes dans la gueule. Comme ça là qui nous a brûlé le visage
Et qui est à moitié mérité comme même parce qu'on a joué avec le feu
Alors, pour des vidéos comme par exemple"Le joueur du grenier" où il base, heu je sais pas,toute sa vidéo sur par exemple Harry Potter
Et qu'il utilise des musiques d''Harry Potter pour plonger les spectateurs dans l'ambiance d'Harry Potter
C'est dégeulasse!
Il mériterait d'avoir une autorisation et d'avoir le droit d'utiliser ça
C'est un peu sa marque de fabrique quand il fait des vidéos à thème comme ça
Mais pour des gens comme moi (rires) des petits chenapans
Où on veut juste faire une blague qu'on veut illustrer par une musique genre le Titanic pendant 4 secondes
Et on n'en démord pas.On veut pas en utiliser une autre!
On veut celle du Titanic!
Alors on peut l'utiliser techniquement
Mais notre vidéo sera juste pas monétisée
Mais comme on veut aller faire nos courses aux galeries de la Fayette!!!
On veut et la musique et la monétisation
Donc on triche!!!!!!!
Et cette petite technique a marché pendant bien longtemps!
Jusqu'à y'a quelques mois quand Universal se sont dit
"Mmmmmh y'a combien à gagner là?"
"Plusieurs dizaine de millions?"
LET'S GOO!!!!!!!!!!!
Ils ont mis leurs meilleurs ingenieurs, leurs meilleurs éléments sur le coup
Et ils ont construit selon moi, c'est pas youtube qui le dit mais, selon moi, un logiciel
qui détecte, une,une mouche qui a été sur un cadavre
touuuuuutes les vidéos qui font des vues, dans lesquelles il y a des musiques qui leur appartient
C'est sûr vu la quantité de vidéos dont ils revendiquent la monétisation
que c'est un logiciel qui détécte tout ça
Mais ce qui est dégeulasse c'est que le logiciel ensuite avertit quelqu'un
de chez Universal qui vient comme ca avec sa petite souris
et qui fait "Hop là"
donc là faut bien comprendre que la revendication de la
monetisation n'est pas automatique comme le fait le robot youtube
mais elle est manuelle et c'est ça qui pose problème
parce que quand le robot youtube detecte dans l'une de tes vidéos
une musique soumise a des droits d'auteurs il détecte sur quel
timecode elle est et il te propose de muter
l'extrait audio en question pour récupérer
ta monétisation... ET HOP comme ça tu peux aller aux
Galeries la Fayette! mais quand c'est une revendication
manuelle, donc fait par quelqu'un de chez Universal
ou un autre Label,  la personne
n'a pas a dire de quand a quand la musique a été utilisée
dans la video
et donc tu n'a pas l'option de muter
uniquement le passage où la musique passe...
afin de récupérer la monétisation.
donc tu te fait complètement niqu*r
et le soucis de ça , c'est que,
universal fait des strikes manuels en masse
mais avec la force de frappe d'un robot.
À mon avis, je pense
qu'ils sont tellement malins
qu'ils arrivent même à classer
dans leur logiciel les vidéos
par ordres de celle qui ont
fait le plus de vues
dans les 24 ou 48 dernière heures.
Et donc celles qui vont
leur rapportaient le plus de thunes.
A aussi le fameux problème moral du
"Tu fais une vidéo de 20 minutes
Tu mets cinq secondes d'une musique
soumise à droit d'auteur.
Et c'est toute la monétisation qui dégage
et qui va au label."
Alors que sa devrait être calculé différemment.
Ça devrait être basé sur le pourcentage de ta vidéo
sur lequel a la musique
ou un truc du genre, voilà.
Les youtubers ragent un peu parce qu'on s'attend à un truc un peu plus juste,
Etant donné que les gens n'ont pas cliqué sur ta vidéo
parce que dedans y'avait par exemple du David Guetta, ils ont cliqué sur ta vidéo
parce que t'as fait une miniature putaclic  et un titre de drannoc
Et la musique qu'il y a dedans, en rien ça t'as fait faire plus de vues donc
pourquoi tout l'argent que ça génère irait label? Bon voilà...
Mais d'un autre coté, comme je l'ai dit, on nous a jamais dit qu'on pouvait utiliser toutes ces musiques soumises à des droits d'auteur
sans aucune répercution, jamais on nous a dit ça
Donc je pense qu'il faut un peu qu'on se remette en question aussi,
et qu'on arrête d'être têtu
Faudrait qu'on crée nos propres musiques, et qu'on les fasse tourner entre nous
Et comme ça, on crée nos propres musique de meme
Non, c'est idée de merde
Alors oui, c'est dommage, on peut pas utiliser des musiques de film dans nos vidéos,
On peut pas parfois même utiliser des musiques de memes parce que quand une musique de Drake devient un meme
Ca reste une musique de Drake, donc clairement ya le label derrière
Mais c'est la vie et faut faire un choix
techniquement, on peut les utiliser mais notre vidéo ne générera pas d'argent, donc c'est un choix.
Mais bonne nouvelle les amis,
YouTube a bien conscience de ce problème-là, de l'abus de droits total des labels, etc
Et du coup, il vont mettre en place une mise à jour où en faite, la personne qui strikera manuellement la vidéo
devra dire le fameux time code, sur lequel se trouve l'extrait de la musique soumise à des droits d'auteur
et du coup, le créateur derrière pourra  cliquer tout simplement sur le fameux bouton
pour muter l'extrait audio en question, et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce qu'universal là, on va pas se mytho, ils ont abusé mon gars!
Donc merci youtube d'avoir écouté ce problème et merci de mettre en place ce truc-là prochainement
je sais pas quand, mais je sais que ça va arriver.
La troisième chose que youtube a faite, et la j'ai vu des gens euhh,
y'a eu un gros quiproquo à propos de ça
et donc du coup, je vais un peu rétablir la vérité, désolé, ça va faire chier certains...
Youtube ont récemment mis en place un programme de lutte contre les réseaux de pédo-pornographie
faut savoir qu'il ya des vrais réseaux qui existent,
que la pédo-pornographie ça existe, que c'est puni très sévèremment par la loi.
Sur Youtube, ya pas mal de vidéos qui présentent des mineurs
des chaines comme par exemple en France, on a studio bubble tea et Neo Swan The voice
Et en gros, c'est des viédos où des enfants vont par exemple ouvrir des jouets, vont faire des activités, etc
et les parents filment tout ça et font une sorte de vlog avec leurs enfants, voilà
Et c'est un truc qui plait aux enfants, et c'est aussi un truc qui plait aux pédophiles
et donc, ah ben, oh non! En disant ce mot elle a sauté, la monétisation!
Y'a même plus besoin d'universal!
Et donc dans certains esapces commentaires de vidéos, du genre,
on peut retrouver des commentaires complètement horribles, abjects,
des commentaires qui relèvent bien sûr de la pédo-pornographie
et surtout, c'est des vidéos qui sont partagées dans des endroits qu dark net, dans des endroits obscurs,
des forums très obscures,
Et c'est là en faite qu'on prend conscience que ça existe et qu'il ya beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup de gens
qui consomment ce genre de trucs et qui sont adeptes à ça
Donc c'est très très grave et horrible !
Et donc youtube bien évidemment sont totalement contre ça
comme chaque être humain sensé...
Et du coup, ils ont mis une mesure en place, ils ont dit :
bon voilà, nous les gars, toutes les vidéos présentant des mineurs, on va supprimer l'espace commentaires
Alors, tous les espaces commentaires des vidéos contenant des mineurs
ne contenaient pas de commentaires pédo-pornographiques
mais youtube a dû ratisser très très très large pour être sûr que ceux qui en contenaient aient bien été dégagés
et youtube a aussi du coup démonétisé les vidéos susceptibles
d'engendrer des commentaire pédo-pornographiques dans l'espace commentaires
Mais ils ont pas DU TOUT démonétisé toutes les vidéos qui contiennent des mineurs
et ça, ça en fait chier beaucoup, et je vous avoue, je comprends pas tant pourquoi...
en faite, ya une sorte de haine générale envers ces chaines-là parce que les gens
trouvent que les parents exploitent leurs enfants
déja le mot "exploiter", il est très fort, c'est un mot qui est très puissant
mais comment vous voulez prouver que les parents de ces chaines exploitent leurs enfants?
On n'en sait rien! On sait pas et c'est très compliqué
Le deuxième arguments que je comprends un peu, mais pareil, faut prendre du recul par rapport à ça,
c'est "Ouais mais regardez, quand l'enfant va grandir, il a toute son enfance comme ça, en public, sur youtube,
les gens vont se moquer de lui à l'école ect
Mais on n'en sait rien ! On n'en sait rien du tout !
C'est les premiers à vivre ça, ya pas eu d'exemples dans le passé de ça,
on sait pas du tout si Neo par exemple quand il va arriver au collège,
les gens vont se moquer de lui ou pas, on n'en sait rien !
Et surtout les gens, on a 20 ans !
Qui on est pour savoir mieux qu'une mère de 40 ans comment s'occuper de ses enfants
et comment gérer ça ?
On est personne ! Regardez, jdois m'occuper d'un chien et j'suis déjà au bout de ma vie !
Je sais pas du tout ce que c'est d'avoir un enfant humain
donc je trouve que c'est un peu hypocrite et je vois là-dedans surtout un bon gros seum,
une bonne grosse jalousie générale, et je trouve qu'autant dans certains cas,
j'avoue, ça à l'air d'être un peu chelou la relation entre les parents et l'enfant,
on voit très bien dans certaines vidéos que l'enfant est vraiment
pas très à l'aise, il aime pas du tout ce moment qu'il est en train de vivre,
on sent même des fois qu'il a envie de faire autre chose, qu'il est un peu forcé etc pour certaines vidéos
donc ça c'est un sujet très compliqué et voilà, comme je vous l'ai dit,
tu vas mettre 10 personnes devant des vidéos d'une des ces chaines youtube-là,
yen a 5 qui vont dire "non, ils exploitent pas leurs enfants"
et 5 qui vont trouver qu'ils exploitent leurs enfants et que c'est pas bien pour les enfants,
mais voilà, c'est des valeurs morales, ça va dépendre de chacun d'entre nous,
on a pas tous le même avis là-dessus,
mais en tous cas, sur ces chaines-là, jsuis désolé, les enfants ont pas l'air en souffrance
ils ont pas l'air d'être en détresse psychologique ou en détresse physique, ils sont,
franchement moi, jvais vous dire, j'aurais adoré, étant plus jeune,
pouvoir aider mes parents déjà à gagner leur vie en faisant des vidéos avec eux
et surtout, vivre des trucs de ouf comme ça !
Ils ouvrent des jouets souvent, ils vont tout le temps dans des bêtes d'endroits
faire des bêtes de choses en famille et c'est trop bien,
ils vivent des trucs génials, géniaux pardon, je sais plus parler
enfin bon voilà, dans certains cas, j'suis d'accord avec les gens qui détestent ces chaines-là,
mais dans d'autres cas, il faut juste qu'on arrête d'avoir le seum contre ça en faite,
y'a pas de raison
et surtout, ce seum-là, cette haine-là qu'on peut avoir vis à vis de ces chaines-là
quand on la met en public, c'est nous en faite, qui faisons du mal aux enfants de ces chaines là
c'est pas les parents, c'est pas la situation du tout, c'est pas le fait qu'ils fassent des vidéos
c'est le fait que des gens comme nous aillent derrière dans les commentaires ou aillent sur les réseaux les bacher
et les démolir. C'est ça qui leur fait du mal, jvous jure
bien plus que leurs parents et que la situation qu'ils sont en train de vivre
Voilà! Je voulais juste m'exprimer là-dessus parce que je vois une haine incroyable envers ces chaines-là
Et ça veut pas dire que toutes les chaines où il y a des mineurs sont clean et que tout se passe bien
les parents sont bienveillants et tout est parfait,
PAS DU TOUUUT
Mais à l'inverse, ça veut pas dire que toutes les chaines comme ça c'est de l'exploitation d'enfants
et c'est les parents qui sont mal intentionnés, qui font pas attention à leurs enfants,
qui font pas ce qu'il faut pour qu'ils aillent bien etc, enfin voilà
Tout n'est pas tout blanc ou tout noir, y'a des entre-deux, attention, faut nuancer tout ça
Et voilà, c'est ce que je voulais faire, je voulais un peu nuancer tout ces trucs-là
parce que je vois vraiment un seum total envers ces chaines-là, et parfois c'est vraiment injustifié.
C'est la fin de ce petit point sur les nouveautés Youtube
du coup, c'est pas "les temps forts sur youtube en février", c'est "Les temps forts DE youtube"
Tout ces trucs-là qui ont été mis en place, c'est très cool, j'espère que youtube va continuer dans cette voie-la
Je trouve qu'avant ils étaient pas du tout transparents et maintenant, ils gagnent en transparence,
Ils se mettent même à faire des sortes de communiqués où ils disent ce qu'il y a de nouveau sur la plateforme etc
Où ils disent les actions qu'ils ont menées au cours des mois passés etc
contre quoi ils ont lutté, ce qu'ils ont mis en place pour détruire le truc etc
enfin, c'est vraiment bien, donc Youtube, continuez comme ça
Et puis pour les youtubeurs qui ne veulent plus être démonétisés, bah je vous invite à utiliser des musiques libres de droits
Voilà, ya plein de sites qui font ça, y'a audiojungle, mais bon, c'est 20$ la musique
Mon grand préféré, c'est EpidemicSound parce que tu peux trier par mood, par genres, par bpm
Fin, par pleins de choses, et du coup, tu trouves beaucoup plus facilement la musique qui est parfaite
pour la situation de ta vidéo que t'avais choisie, et
Surtout, ça fonctionne par abonnement et  en faite, plus t'as d'abonnés, plus tu paies cher.
Un youtuber qui a plus d'argent va payer plus et un youtuber qui a moins d'argent va payer moins
Et ça, c'est très cool!
Donc voilà, je vous le conseille, je mets mon petit lien de parrainage si vous avez envie de m'aider, voilà tout simplement...
Sinon, j'vous laisse aller sur le site sans passer par mon lien de parrainage
et puis voilà, vous en faites par pour tout ceux-là, qui ont UMG, dans pas longtemps,
les prochaines vagues de revendications, on pourra muter l'extrait audio en question
et récupérer la monétisation et ce sera bien
Oh la caméra s'est arrêtée! Ça c'est comme quand un youtuber est démonétisé...
C'est ce qui lui arrive, il disparait comme ça pendant 1 heure, dans la tristesse et il achète un kebab
Et ben on se quitte sur un écran noir, tant pis, plus de batterie...
C'est dommage parce que là je faisais l'un des meilleurs trucs que j'aie fait sur ma chaine
Honnêtement, si seulement  vous pouviez voir...
*bisous* C'est vraiment *bisous, puis léchage de la pauvre poupée ornée de la tête de Jackie Chan..*
*musique outro*